never one wing
anne wintour y santín out en el new york
help 2 wanderers tanguarín same cumplís
web your hands say say'
bien
qué linda número de gente que saluda
digamos que ese número fue la gente que
me entendió y salimos a seguirme la
corriente puede que otro 10% más
entendido y nos haya animado y el resto
quedó así que dice esta mujer
lo mismo pasa con algo así el otro día
una amiga me mandó este audio
hola comandadas si no te me ría pero
como se llama esta canción que dice your
dragon
en él
esta tienda psicología por suerte no se
dedicó a la música
creo que todos pueden claramente
identificar cuál es la canción en la que
hace referencia
pero podrían decirme qué es lo que dice
la canción o cantan todos y bueno one
acaso no estudiaron el verbo to be
lo que dice la canción es vos sos el que
quiero
como lo veo yo lo que pasa es un poco el
resultado de la educación que tuvimos
los que tuvieron un poco más de suerte
aprendieron y los que no cantan i wanna
one pero lo paradójico es que todos
sabemos lo importante que es aprender
inglés es muy importante porque
pareciera que de generación en
generación repetimos que es súper
necesario que vas a conseguir un mejor
trabajo que te abre puertas que vas a
poder viajar a todos lados que cuando
seas grande me lo vas a agradecer
eso me decía mi mamá y si hoy le
agradezco pero poco reflexionamos al
respecto de por qué como cuando es bueno
y beneficioso aprender un idioma
y les voy a mostrar una imagen
podrían en sus mentes completar esta
frase
yo creo que la verdad mayoría puede
decir a playfutbol oa lo mejor alguno
que otro más creativo hay live fútbol o
haya plate fútbol esos son más
afortunados
no es que yo les esté leyendo la mente
es que probablemente ustedes hayan
aprendido como yo a completar el espacio
en blanco a repetir después de la profe
a unir con flechas a rodear la mejor
opción estamos programados para poder
completar el espacio en blanco pero nos
costaría horrores identificar las
palabras por separado en una canción y
ni hablar de usarlas en contexto
antes la forma de estudiar era siempre
una
y mi forma de estudiar también
hay sentada frente a un libro intentando
estudiar un poco inglés al igual que lo
hacemos todos incluso mi hermana y mi
papá intentando explicarme que
desistieran de pupila eran la profe y el
alumno tal como él lo había aprendido en
la secundaria allá por los años 70
traduciendo cada palabra pero lástima
que mi libro en inglés por lo menos no
decía pupil por ningún lado porque en mi
época al noventa y pico se asustaba
stevens así que imagínense qué efectiva
que fue la ayuda
nosotros
aprendimos primero los números después
los colores después la familia o los
juguetes que alguien más compiló en un
libro por vaya a saber uno qué razón y
que a veces no los conocíamos o ni
siquiera eran de nuestro agrado
y aprendió cómo son sentadas frente a un
libro viendo imágenes de otros jugar
dialogar viajar
de ellos a ver quién contesta quiénes
fueron los afortunados realmente de
tener el libro
a color
digamos que yo fui una porque era la más
grande de tres hermanos en cambio mis
hermanos tuvieron la suerte de tener las
respuestas escritas en el libro porque
por más de que nosotros borramos las
respuestas el trazo del lápiz y siempre
quedaba ahí y con un simple movimiento
de cabeza coordinado con el libro las
respuestas se veían
igualmente mis papás fueron bastante
inteligentes y el libro de colores
el libro de actividades los fotocopiaron
ahora pensemos lo seriamente lo mismo
tener el libro color que en blanco y
negro
es lo mismo ver esto
esto
los colores despiertan cosas en nosotros
nos entusiasman nos emocionan nos
relajan nos dan ganas de mirar de buscar
de explorar tal como la vida misma a
full color a high definition yo creo que
ya incluso para mi época el blanco y
negro
era viejo
ahora retomemos un poco como aprendíamos
por lo general al menos
nuestro objetivo principal era completar
el espacio en blanco
yo por ejemplo siempre fui visual y me
acordaba perfecto de donde estaba y de
qué color era en la hoja esa palabra que
yo necesitaba para poder completar el
espacio en blanco pero muchas veces no
me acordaba de la palabra algunos de mis
amigos eran más auditivos se acordaban
del sonido pero no cómo se escribía
entonces el 3 era otra
complejos y algunos otros contaban con
los dedos want to drink y cada cual le
aplicaba una técnica distinta según
howard gardner psicólogo y profesor
norteamericano se pueden distinguir doce
tipos de inteligencia 12 algunas horas
nombramos la visual la auditiva la
sinestésica el movimiento y cada cual
aprende de acuerdo a cómo es
pero ahora si un mismo concepto lo
miramos lo escuchamos lo cantábamos lo
actuamos lo experimentamos
no importa qué tipo de inteligencia
tengamos lo incorporamos
edgard y le dice que sólo recordamos un
5% de las cosas que escuchamos
un 20 por ciento de lo que vemos
un 30 de lo que vemos y escuchamos
simultáneamente un 75 de lo que hacemos
y para que lo tengan en cuenta un 90 de
lo que hacemos y decimos
está claro que al menos los que fueron
saludar antes fueron los afortunados de
haber aprendido inglés de la forma en
que lo hicieron porque si lo tenemos en
cuenta de él solo nos quedó un 30% lo
que vimos y escuchamos bueno
miren esta imagen alguien puede ver lo
que están haciendo los chicos acá
con narices de colores planchando
partes del cuerpo que creen ustedes que
están haciendo a los chicos ahí
la respuesta rápido yo creo que es
jugando si fehacientemente están jugando
de su objetivo principal cada uno al
juego que más le gusta y de la forma que
más cómodo se siente y con quién más
tranquilo está colores números partes
del cuerpo
oraciones afirmativas negativas
interrogativas en presente en pasado en
futuro todo el mismo tiempo y sin darse
cuenta que están en la clase de inglés
yo me acuerdo que una de las cosas por
las cuales al menos yo no quería ir
inglés de chica era porque además de que
para mí era súper aburrido
era porque todas mis amigas iban a sus
casas cuando a jugar cuando yo me tenía
que quedar en la escuela estudian inglés
sentada con un libro
hoy los chicos tienen esta posibilidad
de aprender jugando
y cada uno aprende de la forma que más
le gusta en esta imagen
vamos a poner un ratito aunque los
chicos no se den cuenta están usando los
dos hemisferios del cerebro al mismo
tiempo todo el cerebro mientras que el
hemisferio izquierdo lógico y analítico
está intentando coordinar algún
movimiento y está ocupado coordinando
ese movimiento o comunicándose el
hemisferio derecho más intuitivo y
emocional sintetiza ese aprendizaje
y qué pasaría si a todo esto le sumamos
un ingrediente casi mágico la música
la música activa el hipotálamo y graba a
través de las emociones un aprendizaje
para siempre para siempre
nunca les pasó que escucha de una
canción en la radio y se transportan en
el tiempo tanto así que se acuerdan de
con quién y dónde estaban
cómo se sentían o incluso hasta de cómo
iban vestidos
realmente el aprendizaje de inglés pasa
a un segundo plano porque estamos
jugando nos estamos divirtiendo
estamos mirando explorando escuchando
estamos generando vínculos con los
padres y con los adultos que nos rodean
estamos viviendo el aprendizaje
los chicos de hoy hay que reconocerlo
son distintos y el momento que les toca
vivir también tengamos en cuenta que
hacen clic y todo está a su alcance en
simultáneo
full color high definition y se
comunican tan fácilmente con un chico el
otra cuadra como con un chico del otro
continente tienen necesidades distintas
y por sobre todo demandan distintos
yo les puedo contar que jamás despedí a
mi papá en inglés pero en mi casa era
obligatorio no había escapatoria hoy los
chicos de temprana edad exigen saber
y los estudios demuestran que cuanto
antes se les exponga un idioma
extranjero mejores van a ser los
resultados a largo plazo
hoy los chicos siguen a instagramers en
inglés a youtubers en inglés miran pelis
y series en inglés
están en un mundo en el que el inglés es
moneda corriente los chicos
exigen saber por esta razón porque viven
en un mundo en el que se comunican en
inglés
antes
cuando nosotros cuando los papás nos
mandábamos a inglés los papás los mandan
inglés a los chicos y los chicos les
piden ir a inglés los papás que los
acompañamos pensando en lo bueno que
sería y todo lo que nos facilitaría hoy
saber hablar inglés los mandamos a
inglés
allí arrancan varias complicaciones
entre ellas la primera es como los
acompañamos a estos chicos que nos piden
hoy ir inglés
si con suerte nos acordamos un 30% de lo
que vimos y escuchamos entonces
conscientes de lo que fue para nosotros
el aprendizaje de idiomas lo intentamos
ayudar a sortear este bodrio de la mejor
manera posible y lo sentamos a repetir
20 líneas destruirán gris tigers les
traducimos cada palabra tal como mis
papás hacían conmigo y les decimos que
en inglés se hizo al revés listo ya
pueden ir a rendir
los chicos son distintos como les decía
siguen a instagramers en inglés miran
series en inglés los games las apps
viven en este mundo que el inglés es
moneda corriente y es por eso que ellos
exigen saber no porque quieran rendir un
examen sino porque quieren ser parte de
este mundo que se comunica en todos los
idiomas
yo creo que cuando arranque aprender
inglés éramos cinco o seis los que nos
quedábamos después de hora en el colegio
porque no era tan común aprender desde
tan chiquititos y eso que yo ya tenía 7
hoy los chicos desde muy temprana edad
a empiezan a aprender inglés
y los estudios demuestran que exponiendo
los desde los primeros años de edad a un
bebé
son mejores los resultados aprenden
mejores las estructuras gramaticales del
acento los sonidos
nosotros nos arrancamos a preguntar pero
como aprende un bebé inglés un bebé sin
ni siquiera se puede sentar en una
sillita
y no le voy a confundir los dos idiomas
y ni siquiera sabe hablar español
y bueno yo les cuento que el menos de mi
experiencia los bebés pueden arrancar
aprender inglés desde los 4 meses de
edad
a esa edad los bebés todavía cuentan con
una plasticidad cerebral que les ayuda a
incorporar todos los conocimientos en
simultáneo
en esa a los 4 meses
los bebés pueden incorporar como
esponjas lo que nosotros le demos eso
vendría a ser en inglés que empiezan a
generar ese cerebro bilingüe
y los beneficios de un cerebro bilingüe
no son solamente saberse comunicar en
otro idioma o mirar las pelis sin
subtítulos o escuchar una canción y
poder cantarla está demostrado que un
cerebro bilingüe es más ágil en la
resolución de problemas
ayuda a la conexión neuronal
fortaleciendo la e incluso ayuda a la
salud mental retrasando la posibilidad
de contraer alzheimer de 4 a 5 años
quien pudiese volver a ser el bebé no
igualmente si hay algo que sí
es importante destacar en este proceso
es que tanto los bebés como nosotros
aprendemos más y mejor acompañados
apuntalados con un vínculo presente en
las clases o fuera de ellas con alguien
que se divierta con nosotros que juegue
con nosotros
incluso
nosotros cuando aprendimos inglés
yo creo que no nos fue tan sencillo por
esta misma razón porque no nos
permitimos jugar no nos permitimos ser
niños por un rato como mi amiga y yo que
después de reírnos largo y tendido del
audio que me mandó les grabamos este
vídeo muchas gracias
[Música]
muchas gracias